[Music]
there's no green thing so i'm
i'm just gonna go i see it okay
all right i'll go yeah um
uh hello my name is uh kit berman i am
a geomex product manager for um the
cancer transcriptomalis it's a pleasure
to be here today
um to talk to you about um dsp the
digital spatial profiler
um and um the cancer transcriptomat list
so um so this is a great technology
from um nanostring of course um you know
as a company we've been around
for quite some time and um many people
know us
for a gene expression uh platform
the encounter analysis system but um in
2019 we actually launched
launched a new system um called the dsp
digital spatial profiler
um that does something really unique
um and delivers um great spatial
information along with
um both protein and gene expression
information so
um and that's really what i'm going to
focus on um today
so i'm sure many users here um perform
some type of bulk gene expression
um you know it's it's a great technology
whether it's
on the end counter or you're using um
rna sequencing
and it tells us a lot about the biology
um here is example of a
signature that was actually developed by
merck
it's called the tumor information
signature
it was developed on encounter but this
concept is definitely
extendable to other disease pathologies
and it basically tells the user
whether or not the tumor itself is
inflamed
whether or not there's an active immune
system
but there's a lot of caveats to these
signatures because
you know it does predict uh response
to therapy in this case but there's many
patients where there might be a high
score but
no response and so we know that it's not
a perfect measure of
whether or not somebody will respond to
a particular therapeutic because there's
such a diversity
in the biology
so to illustrate that with
images i have two uh colorectal
carcinomas here
um and these tissues
have almost the same inflammation score
we can see there on the top right of
each section so two different patients
you know one has you know the uh
immune system on the left inside in
magenta you can see that it hasn't
really infiltrated the tumor which is in
green which is pan cytokeratin
um but on the right you can see this
really highly infiltrated tumor where
the immune cells the cd3 t cells and the
cd45
cells are infiltrating into the green
portion
and so these two patients even though
they have the same level of information
you know are going to their same level
and same scores are going to have two
very different responses
and so you know what's lost in these
bulk gene expression assays
is some of this spatial information and
that's why it's so important
to help us understand the biology
of cancer but you know and generally
biology across the board
in all different domains
so that's really where uh the digital
spatial profiler comes in
it helps you take this high plex gene
expression information or protein
expression information and merges it
with um
the spatial data that you get from
a tissue section right so you both get
the
precision and quantification that you
would expect
from these county assays but also
kind of the contextual information of
where this signal is actually coming
from
so on the dsb system
it basically takes a standard tissue
section slide
and so you know there's numerous
different
sample types that you can use on our
particular platform
both ffpe which we've optimized all our
assays for
so forming fixed paraffin-embedded
samples or you know fresh frozen samples
a lot of people will use tumor
microarrays on the platform um
so it's pretty flexible in the input as
long as you can put it on a slide
you can run it on our platform
so this is a nice general overview of
the dsp process on the left hand
side you have our reagents and so this
is a lot of where the power is in the
platform
we either use antibodies for protein
detection
or ish probes for rna detection
and so um you have on each probe
is a attached a dna oligo or dsp
barcode um through a uv photo cleavable
linker
right so this allows us to you know
stain these tissues and mass
with the probes and then what the dsp
system does it allows you to visualize
your tissue
then select a region of interest and
then it shines a uv
light in a specific region that you've
selected
and it illuminates only that region
while leaving everything else untouched
and it leaves your tissue intact very
importantly it doesn't destroy your
tissue
the because the dsp dna oligos the dsp
barcodes are attached
um via uv photo cleavable linker
when the uv light hits those specific
regions the
dna oligos come off the tissue and then
we collect and distribute
them in uh well of a 96 well plate
so then that allows those dsp barcodes
or the dna oligos to be counted
um on the back end so what that gives
you
is a very distinct profile quantitative
profile of what's expressed
in each region of interest so you can
see on the right you have
each circle there it's a this is a lymph
node biopsy
and you can see each circle you'll have
a unique
profile for every single one of these so
instead of having
a gene expression signature across the
whole tissue
you can now get a gene expression or
protein expression profile
for every single region that you've
selected and so now you can place those
regions
in spatial context
so just real briefly we have a number of
different reagents so we have
protein assays for
immune oncology uh immunology um as well
as
neuroscience panels so this is really
our protein offerings we
have pre-validated content for fallen
fixed pair of embedded samples um right
now everything's enabled to be read out
on the encounter uh platform meaning
those
dna oligos that come off the tissue are
read out on the encounter
and we're building out the capability to
have those read out on
the ngs platform now
um the readout of these ngs
these dsp barcodes or
dna algos the readout on
for our smallplex panels for rna
or and the encounter
and then we've expanded the readout
using the ngs system so illumina's
ngs readout so that we can actually read
out um
a large number of genes all at once so
for the cancer transcriptome atlas um we
have the ability to read
over 1800 genes at one time from every
single
region of interest so this is obviously
a large amount of information
from every single region so instead of
looking at the cancer transcriptome
across the whole tissue
you can look at it at various regions
throughout your tissue
and so these have the 1800 genes here
are specific to
um immune oncology um
and then just to introduce you into what
we're doing we're
um launching next year early next year
is the whole transcriptome atlas and so
this will be for human and for mouse the
other two panels were for
uh human but this will be uh
able you'll be able to measure basically
the whole transcriptome
in every single region of interest so a
truly unbiased assay
um so all the protein-coding genes
so to focus a little more on the atlas
that we use today
this has over 1800 genes it covers
a wide array of pathways so everything
from you know b-cell and t-cell biology
to stromal architecture and the immune
micro-environment
um also quite a bit of tumor biology
and so this targets you know things like
cytokines and chemokines and
growth factors and so forth
there's a lot of annotations in this
particular panel we've uh
borrowed a lot from our encounter panels
so it has a lot of the
uh immunology signatures that you would
expect like pam50
or the tumor information signature or a
set of genes
and of course there's the ability to add
custom targets
so this is the the panel that i'll show
you some data
uh with today and this is
actually read out on an illumina
sequencer so
once you have collected the bar codes
the dna goes from the tissue
using the digital spatial profiler
you'll simply read that out
on the illumina sequencer and
then import that data back into our
system
so just to review um you'll take your
your section and you'll sustain it with
both imaging reagents which is an
important part of the
roi selection strategy you know um these
are
roughly labeled antibodies or they can
be ish probes
rna scope is compatible with our
platform
and so you'll stain it with those
imaging reagents and then
you'll also use our profiling reagents
so those are either the protein panels
or
the rna probes the cta in this case the
cancer transcription atlas
you'll prepare the sample and then
you'll place it on the digital spatial
profiler
um and on the instrument you'll actually
select your regions of interest and i'll
kind of dig into what that actually
means and the flexibility of that
process
but then the system will allow you to um
cleave the old goes from every specific
region it collects those logos and
dispenses them in a play in a well and
96 well played
and then you count them on either the
end counter or the aluminum signature
so this just shows you the
reproducibility of the platform
you know these are on the right hand
side you can see two serial sections
lymph node sections and then you can see
the reproducibility of the correlation
between uh selecting the same region
across two different serial sections so
uh
0.983 uh r squared value
um you know this will really this high
level of reproducibility
um allows you to you know basically
measure biological change um
you know very precisely and you can see
another thing to point out here is that
there's a large dynamic range
as you'd expect from this many uh
targets
so you see things that are highly
expressed but you also are able to
discern low expressors as well
so up to this point we've um i've shown
you these spatial images with
circles basically regions of interest
where we've created a polygon or a
circle
selected it and then illuminated that
particular circle
but on the instrument is a
digital micro mirror device that allows
us to finally
shape the uv light source like a mask
and so here in the middle having a this
is a
just a core from the tma um
and you could just create a circle and
take the whole core
as one profile but using this
dmd device we can actually
cut apart the tumor
and the tumor micro environment from one
from another
so it actually allows us to finally
dissect out the two different
signatures and so in this particular
example
we'll get a profile for the tumor which
is on top
and then we'll get another profile for
the tumor microenvironment so we
actually have two distinct
either protein or gene expression
profiles for what we're trying to study
and this really allows you to see the
interaction
between those two different segments
so we've been running projects for quite
some time and so
um over the years we've developed um
different
profiling strategies um so obviously the
simplest approach would be
geometric um and many people like to do
this because it allows them to just play
circles or squares or polygons over
regions that have some
morphologically distinct on aspect to
them so
you know putting them in regions with
heavy amount of infiltrate
or positive for a particular signal or a
particular morphological feature
um such as a part of the the anatomy
so they can simply mean move these
uh circles on top of it or you know
shape a polygons and kind of fit
whatever they're trying to study you can
take this a step further and segment
so basically segmentation allows you to
basically segment on the fluorescence
that you're looking at
and say i want everything that's
positive for panasonic keratin
or i want everything that is negative
for a particular
fluorescent marker and so it allows you
kind of like we said
cut apart different uh segments from
maybe the tumor from
the immune cells that aren't treating it
and then just an extension of that would
be looking at you know
cell type specific population so
basically selecting all the t
cells or all the b cells in our
particular region
um and then there's also contouring
which allows you
to look at biological gradients in a
particular tissue
um so
so going back to our example here um we
have two very different
tumors that have the same bulk signature
but
we want to profile them so that we could
really pick apart what's happening here
in a spatial manner so
you could just draw geometric circles
over each one of those
and we can see here at the top we have
um you know non-infiltrated tumor
regions right and so you can see that in
green and then at the bottom
we have these infiltrated tumor regions
and it's not annotated here but
the pink on the left are really
the immune environment and so the
infiltrated tumor regions look a lot
like
the immune positive regions
right the magenta which is cd45
um and so we can really tell that
there's something unique about the tumor
um in both regions one in the top
tumor somehow the tumor is excluding the
immune system
whereas the immune system in the bottom
one is able to get past that barrier and
infiltrate
so um we really you know we have this
this
tumor immune boundary here we really
want to uh
better characterize it so how do we
characterize
this uh this invasive margin
and so one way to do that would be to
select these three different regions of
interest
and then we can actually contour across
the region
so you know we draw the boundary and
then we're able to
segment each one of these regions across
boundaries so
um we've taken three regions of interest
and we've basically split it up into
different
contours so every conjoi here is going
to have
its own profile and so that
allows us to ask a lot of questions
about the tumor immune boundary in this
particular patient
and so we can see that you know the gene
expression profile
change from when we go inside of the
tumor at outside we see net gene
heavily expressed within the tumor we
can see
the hla dra gene expressed in the tumor
and then across the boundary um you know
of course
chemokines are not highly expressed
within the tumor
but then mhc class 2 molecules are
highly expressed
along the border but then decrease the
farther away
that you get so you really get to see in
this particular roi
uh the changes across the boundary and
how the biology is
how the tumor is interacting with the
immune environment
and then the great thing about the dhp
platform is built for large cohorts of
samples so here we have
two different patients one is the highly
infiltrated tumor and the other one is
the
immune excluded tumor but the system is
really designed to
um have large cohords whether they're
tmas or you're running
24 or 48 slides through the system you
can take all that data and put it
together
um so here we're looking at you know the
differences in
the immune response of cd8 and cd3
t cells across the immune boundary
and each dot here is a different measure
at a different point along the
boundary we can see things like
you know in this case the inflammatory
macrophages
are enriched in the
inflamed tumor with the heavily
infiltrated
t cells we can see that distinct
difference here
and you know this kind of shows us that
there's a strong
m1 and m2 macrophage polarization
with that particular patient that has
heavily infiltrated
[Music]
immune cells into the tumor
um and we can also take this data and we
could you know apply
pathway analysis to it so you can take
things like you know an infra
interference
signaling pathway and you can basically
measure it
across the border and what we're seeing
here is you know we've taken many
uh tumor stroma boundaries across the
whole tissue
and you know each line here may it could
be a different
boundary
so there are other things that we can
ask with these particular samples
um we you know maybe we want to know how
the
t cell functions are different depending
on if it's
a infiltrated tumor versus one that has
a strong boundary
and so we can do that here we've
selected regions that are inside the
tumor
and we've selected regions that are
outside the tumor so we want to know how
the t cells are changing if they're able
to get inside the tumor
um you know how are they able to
overcome this barrier
and why are you know some t cells kind
of hanging outside
the tumor boundary and so what we're
able
to do is basically
select all the t cells and then we can
select everything that neighbors
a t cell right so you get both this
profile for what is happening in the t
cells
and then you can see how it's actually
affecting the environment around it
um and so we can see things obviously um
you know just as a
um control your cd3 is highly expressed
in
t cells obviously and low league spread
c in the neighbor
compartment but then you have um you
know things like
um tim3 which is up regulated in t
cells within the tumor but not so much
in the stromal environment when
those in the stronghold environment same
with 41 bb so you kind of pick apart
the different t cell profiles for those
that are
inside the tumor versus outside of the
tumor
and and this is just uh some follow-up
experiments that we did with uh
interferon gamma
and rna scope to show you know that
inflamed phenotype
and so the last thing i want to show you
is um
just an example that
[Music]
that a customer did for
a conference earlier this year and so
one thing that we found is a lot of
people have either bulk
or single cell rna-seq information that
they want to integrate
spatially um and so single star and i
think has been great because it tells
you a lot about these populations of
cells but it doesn't really tell you
where these cells are and so
we've developed methodologies to help
our customers do just that
so this is alex warwick from the garvin
institute and
he's been working with triple negative
breast cancer
and so he performed um an analysis
with actually our whole transcriptome
atlas assay um where he was looking at
different
cell types um in the tls structures
within the triple negative breast
cancers and so
um just to give you the high level
overview
he took his single cell rna-seq
signatures
because you can identify these very
clear populations of cells
he then created rois here in the middle
um and then segmented on out of keratin
and then
the stromal environment so really
everything else that it wasn't tumor
and then using these signatures he was
able to
deconvolute the data and understand
the um composition of each of these
segments and so
you could actually tell which cells were
in each of these segments
in these two regions and then across his
tissues in general
so it's a really good way to kind of
integrate both your your single cell
data
whether it's in cancer or neuro or any
other
tissue and take your single cell data
and then use it in your
geomets dsp experience so
with that i want to thank everybody for
your attention and interest
um you know feel free to reach out with
any questions
um and um you know you can find this
single cell dcon on bioarchives the
algorithm that we've just published
or you know more information about
geomex and
the cancer transcription analyst by
emailing geomx management.com
thank you
okay awesome job well we're all set
over here i'll just do some uh quick
editing on the front and back end since
there was
no interruptions in between your
presentation and um
then i'll have it ready for the event um
in a few days
okay i will uh just send you that one
slide um
all i did was drop out uh
just the this i don't know if you can
see it but on slice 12
i just cut out the right side so i'll
just send you that one slide
okay that sounds good i'll keep an eye
out for it and then um
i will be sure to replace it while we're
doing some editing
okay did anything else go wrong or is it
good no everything else
uh went great i can send over a preview
link once it's ready
um and then you can take a look then if
you'd like to
okay i'll just i'll just click through
unlock but uh i'm sure
i don't you know i'm sure my schedule
does not allow for me to be listening to
this over again
okay okay thank you well if any
questions come up feel free to reach out
if not
then we'll talk to you soon all right
sounds good thanks tyler bye